there Before we jump into today's paper
I just want to give a shout out to
machine learning Straight Talk where
every week we talk about current or big
trends or topics in machine learning the
first discussion that we launched is
actually on today's paper
the enhanced poet so if you like the
following video you might want to jump
over to machine learning Street Talk and
check out our discussion about it it's
very interesting all right have fun
hi there what you're seeing here are
many different environments from a
single run of a system that's called the
enhanced poet last time we've taken a
look at a system called poet and the
enhanced poet is kind of an improvement
over the original poet fixing some of
its shortcomings and you see here that
the city agent is able to solve this
very very diverse set of of environments
and the notable thing is this is from a
single run of this algorithm so one run
will produce all these different
environments and will produce agents
that are able to solve all the different
environments at the same time in
parallel so it's a population-based
method if you haven't seen the video I
did on poet I suggest you go and see
that now this is simply an enhancement
to it and I expect people to know kind
of what I'm talking about
alright it's gonna be a short video but
I think it is a good addendum to poet so
it's the enhanced poet open-ended
reinforcement learning through unbounded
invention of learning challenges and
their solutions by Roy Wang Chu layman a
deterent wall geol-chi
you'll only Jeff Clun and Kenneth Oh
Stanley so we'll jump right in they make
a number of improvements to the original
poet and I simply want to discuss the
most important ones so you know they
have a nice graphic down here of what
happens in
what poet built up this tree of
environments into each environment it
has an agent that it trains to solve
that environment at the same time so at
the same time it will kind of start out
here it will generate offspring it will
generate continuously generate offspring
and then it will also continuously train
agents in each environment that it
produced in order to solve that
environment and it keeps doing that
while producing more and more offspring
and then once in a while it does what is
called a transfer so that means that for
example you see here the offspring
produced here from this environment you
cannot see that the lineage here kind of
kind of our focus is on squigly
environments right you see that there's
a little squiggle here and a bit of a
squiggle here and then the offspring all
of a sudden is a bit more smooth but has
this this little step here and then this
offspring of this environment has this
large step here that agents that come
from here have can have been optimized
to solve the squiggly this problem but
here over here this lineage has
specified or specialized more and more
in kind of like these kind of large
drops or steep hills so the agent that
was trained over here was found to be
very effective in this environment and
therefore can be transferred so this
kind of population branching out into
the different trees and then
transferring solutions between the parts
of the trees that's what makes poet very
very powerful mechanism to solve these
these kind of tasks alright so how does
this improve now first thing that poet
does is it generates these environments
and it always wants to generate new
environments so it always generates
offspring to each environment so let's
say we are here it generate
generate offspring to each environment
here right each that we have let's see
we have only seen so far and then it
only picks the most novel ones the ones
that are most novel which is this
probably this then there are other
criteria namely that it can be solved by
some agents but it cannot be solved by
other so it's not too difficult but also
not too hard but one of the aspects is
it must be novel right so we're not
seeing any here which means that those
weren't novel enough how does it measure
novel in the original implementation of
poet you had this environment generator
which was like a level generator which
made these gaps here and the stumps here
and you could specify I believe five
numbers so there was a five-point scale
in which you could specify how high the
stumps were right you get this kind of
Pentagon here how high the stumps were
and how deep the gaps were and how rough
the terrain was and the level generator
would generate this level and so you're
basically your distance metric between
environments was a vector of size five
right this is environment one and you
had environment to which if it's more it
has higher stumps right then this
particular number here maybe would be
higher than this number here so it was
kind of limited to taking the Euclidean
distance between two environment
encodings in order to measure the
distance between environments this is
very very domain-specific and the
authors here are view what we should
rather do is have a general environment
agnostic distance measured metric right
so here is what they proposed they
proposed the following
why don't we if we have a new
environment right let's say we have a
new environment we measure all of the
agents
the current agents and ones we've
already seen right we measure all the
agents in our database on this new
environment that's this and they come up
with scores right each of them gets a
score and then we you know clip and
bound the score so the max here is 300
and the minimum is 50 but in any case we
then rank them right so we evaluate them
and then we rank them from best to worst
and then we normalize which simply means
that the best one gets a score of 0.5
and the worst one gets a score of
negative 0.5 and now this vector here
this is now used to compare environments
so if we have another environment right
right here we have a two and that gets a
different ordering right so maybe agent
one is now the best agent two is really
bad and so on right that gets a
different ordering then the resulting
vector here will be very very different
from from this vector right here and
this is very agnostic so no matter which
environment it is if the ordering of
agents in it the score they get the
order of it is the same the environments
aren't really different from each other
they authors argue but if the scores are
very differently ranked right so imagine
the environment is harder but
essentially the same then the scores
will be lower but still the agents would
be ranked the same so you can argue well
that's just kind of the same environment
it buttocks except a step like this it
now has a super-steep step right it's
not very different but if you know if
instead of that you get an environment
that is like this like you say wow
that's qualitatively different and you
would expect from this one to this one
that the agents performance would
roughly stay
the same but you would expect from the
middle one to this one that an entirely
different set of agents might perform
well right in this one so that's how
novelty is measured and I think it's
it's a pretty cool cool way I don't have
coronavirus by the way maybe who knows
oh um no I just have a dry throat
alright so this is the first enhancement
they make is that they measure novelty
in this domain agnostic way really cool
so far and what this allows them to do
this allows them to actually not rely on
this level generator with the five with
you know the five parameters in order to
generate these levels but these levels
cannot be produced however they want
with different generators and that's
exactly what they do they now employ
neural networks not well it's it's kind
of a proto typical it's a called a a C
PLN that generates these things you
might have seen in the examples the
enhanced poet doesn't have these gaps
and stumps anymore
it simply has these landscapes that are
super diverse but they're still just
their landscapes and what it does is it
evolves neural networks at the same time
as it evolves the population it evolves
these so the architecture of these
networks isn't fixed it's actually
evolving along with the agent to make
the challenges harder and harder so you
see there are like cosines and sines in
here and you can add them and subtract
and so on and that will give you a
mapping from X which is the x-coordinate
here to Y which is the y-coordinate all
right and that will give you kind of a
continuous landscape depending on the
architecture here and on the internal
parameters of course I guess there would
also be a node some here like times a
lambda factor and then the lambda would
also be
a thing that is evolved so pretty cool
of course the internals of this now
aren't just described by a fixed vector
anymore but you don't need that anymore
because we have a method to compare
environments even if they come from
completely different architectures of
generators right so it's pretty cool
that the D agnostic comparison of
environments allows you to now have a
much more general level generator and of
course now produce much more diverse
environments and that's what they
exactly what they see of course is here
the environments get super crazy
so they also propose kind of a novel
metric to measure novelty sorry to
measure progress so the question is how
do we measure progress in these
algorithms in these open-ended
algorithms and what they propose is this
and next score which is I have to go and
look it up the annex score I think is
the number of new environments that are
solved right yes so exactly the question
is whether a system continues to
generate interesting new things and the
way they measure it is by the
accumulated number of novel environments
created and solved right so the question
here is accumulated that means over the
entire run they count up how many
environments that they've seen that are
novel and we've already had the
definition of novel and in this case
basically means that it must pass the
minimal criterion is neither too hard
nor too easy we've already seen this in
how the offspring of environments is
generated right there's a minimal
criterion and
and it must be eventually solved so that
means the northern mime environments
created and solved right so how many new
environments are created and then at a
later point solved you can see the
difference to the original poet in this
graph so the original poet eventually
runs out of new environments because
it's generator is just not powerful
enough we can only modify these five
variables and eventually the environment
aren't substantially novel from the old
environments whereas the enhance part
you can see even after this run and I'm
sure they have large infrastructure to
do these experiments it just continues
to innovate new more elaborate
environments continuously so this I
think are the main the main things they
also do some improvement to the
transfers and so on I don't want to go
into that I just wanted to show these
improvements so that you have the
complete picture of how such an
algorithm runs my criticism to this is
that if you just look at their their
thing is that with the within the
leaving out of the gaps and the stumps
and so on in a weird way of course the
levels are diverse but they have become
even more similar it seems like you're
really relying on the of your ability to
to kind of continuously crazy slow kind
of like a again four levels right and
you're relying on your ability to
smoothly increase the difficulty of the
levels right - to actually have a
diversity in your level generator but
also a kind of a smoothness with regard
to the difficulty and in order to build
this whole curriculum and I think even
though the environments look more
diverse it might be going into a
direction where you kind of engineer
yourself into a corner where you are now
even more and more relying on these
these evolving
parametrize about generators nonetheless
the ideas I think are pretty cool and
that's all I have to say about it
bye-bye